hello everyone
my name is andreas pope and i'm going to
present our paper
titled sequential defaulting in
financial networks
which is a joint work with roger
watanover
so the talk is going to focus on
modeling and understanding financial
networks
which is a very important and timely
topic
if you want to analyze the situation of
a bank or some other financial
institution today
then you cannot just look at this single
bank separately
because nowadays the financial system is
in fact the network of many banks that
are interconnected by various kinds of
debt contracts
and if one of the banks goes bankrupt
and cannot base liabilities
then this means that other banks do not
receive their money
so they also go bankrupt and so on it
can cause a cascading effect through the
whole network
and because of this the network-based
study of these financial systems
has been rapidly gaining attention in
the last few years
the base model to study these systems
originally developed by eisenberg and
noe
is actually quite simple and we do need
to introduce some financial terminology
for it but
it is just a very natural description of
what happens in a network
we have some banks or nodes and each
bank has a certain amount of available
money or
funds in its possession that we show in
these little rectangles
beside the node and these banks are
connected by debt contracts
which say that for example bank you has
to pay one unit of money to bank v
and this naturally describes a specific
amount of assets and liabilities for
each bank
for example you receives one unit of
payment on its incoming debt contract
and has funds of three on its own so
altogether it has a sets of four
on the other hand it has a liability of
one towards bank we so
since it has more than enough assets to
fulfill these obligations
it will make a payment of one on the
step contract and
keep the remaining three units of money
to itself
however bankwii has one unit of money
itself
and receives a payment of one from you
so it has a sets of two
but on the other hand it has total
liabilities of four towards these two
sync nodes
so this is an example of the case when v
is unable to fulfill its obligations
in this case we say that bank we is
bankrupt or in financial terms
v is in default in this case the model
assumes that we must use
all of its assets to make as much
payments on these outgoing debts as
possible
and it makes this payment proportionally
to the payment obligations
so in this case it will transfer one
unit of money to both of the sync nodes
furthermore we don't not only care if v
is in default or not
but we are also interested in the
so-called recovery rate of v
that is the proportion of payment
obligations that v is able to fulfill
denoted by rv in this case this is 2
over 4 or 1 half
and in general if v is not in default
then its recovery rate is one it can
fulfill
all its obligations and if v is in
default then its recovery rate is
strictly less than one
and since the payments on each edge are
proportional to the liabilities this
also means that we will always pay
an rv portion of the payment obligations
on each outgoing debt
so this simple model has already been
studied in various works
because it already allows us to see how
a single default can cause ripple
effects throughout network
also the model is rather simple and nice
from a computational point of view
in the sense that apart from some
degenerate cases
it only has one solution that is one
configuration of payments that satisfies
these rules
and this solution can be computed in
polynomial time
however the model is also quite limited
in the sense that
it cannot model various other aspects of
real-world systems
for example in practice banks often have
other types of financial derivatives on
each other
that create very different kind of
connections in the sense that a worse
situation for one bank
creates a more favorable outcome for
another bank
so to all the also modeled these kinds
of scenarios
the recent work of shooting success and
bathstand has introduced a more
sophisticated financial network model
that also allows conditional debt
contracts where the payment obligation
depends on some specific
event in the system and in particular
they have extended the model by allowing
so-called
cdss or credit default swaps where this
event is a default
and indeed in practice these cds's are a
very popular kind of financial
derivative
which have also played a dominant role
in the financial crisis of 2008.
so the main idea of a cds is that banks
you
and v make a contract that if a specific
third bank goes into default
then and only then you has to pay two
units of money to v
and what makes this more interesting
from our perspective
is that disturbed bank might just be
another bank of our financial network
so in general there are various possible
reasons why
v would enter into such a cds contract
uh maybe it's just a speculative bet for
v who has heard that
rumor that w is going to go into default
but in many cases a cds is used as a
kind of insurance policy
imagine that w has a payment obligation
towards v
and for some reason we suspect that w
will not be able to fulfill this
application
then we might decide to enter into a cds
in reference to w
then if w really goes deep into default
then at least we receive some payment
from the cds instead
on the other hand if w can fulfill its
applications then v
does not get any money on the cts but at
least it receives its payment from w
and while this already describes the
general idea cds are in fact a bit more
sophisticated in the sense
that the payment obligation is actually
proportional
to 1 minus the recovery rate of w
we have already seen two extremes of
this when w
is not in default then there is no
payment obligation on the cds at all
and then w cannot pay at all then the
payment obligation is the entire weight
of the cds
but we can also be in between where for
example rw is one half
and then the obligation on the cts
scales linearly between these two
extremes
so let us see a simple example for such
a financial system with both
tabs and cdss and this system we have a
bank you and the bank we
that both have an outgoing debt of 1 and
an incoming cts
in reference to each other where if you
recall these cds's
imply a payment obligation of this
amount
so here we can first of all note that
the source node has
enough funds to pay for its liabilities
in any case
so we can just pretend for simplicity
that it has infinitely many funds
also the sync node does not have any
liabilities so
it cannot go into default either so the
interesting part of this system
is the recovery rates of unv
so assume first that u is in default and
cannot pay any of its liabilities
this means that on the lower cds we have
a payment obligation
of two so v receives two units of money
which means that it can make a payment
of one
so it has a recovery rate of one since
it pays all of its liabilities
in this case on the upper cds you
receives no payment at all
so it cannot make any payments which is
indeed consistent to the fact that ru is
zero
on the other hand we get a symmetric
situation if we assume
that v is in default with rv equals 0
then on the upper cds there is a payment
obligation of 2
and with these 2 units of money you can
pay its liabilities
which means that it has a recovery rate
of 1.
in this case the lower cds has a payment
obligation of zero
uh so v has no assets which is indeed
consistent with the fact that rb is zero
so these are both solutions equilibrium
points of this system
and in fact a deeper analysis shows that
there is also a search solution
where both u and v are in default with
recovery rates of two certs
in this case on both of the cds we will
have a payment obligation
of two search so both u and v
can pay two search to the sync node
which is consistent with the recovery
rates
this means that the system has three
very different equilibria
and this also poses a conflict of
interest between the different nodes
since we would clearly prefer the first
equilibrium where v is not in default
while you would prefer the second
equilibrium where u is not in default
which raises a lot of curious questions
and indeed there have been multiple
previous works that studied this
financial network model but
interestingly they have only studied the
model in terms of these equilibria that
we see here
analyzing whether they exist whether
they are hard to find how to modify them
and this is indeed a valid approach when
for example we have a large financial
crisis
and the authorities have to look at the
entire system in a centralized manner
and decide who is in default and who is
not
however apart from these rare occasions
the system usually develops in a
sequential manner in practice
one bank announces a default then
another one announces the default
sometime later
and so on in such a step-by-step fashion
and there are many natural questions
that only arise if we study this
evolution of this system
so our main goal in this talk is to
study such a sequential model of
financial systems
where the process consists of discrete
time steps that we call updates
essentially we assume that banks always
have an official
announced recovery rate which might not
equal their
current balance and every step of the
process consists
of a specific bank adjusting its
official recovery rate
to the one that would follow from the
current state of the system
for example each node begins with an
official recovery rate of 1
which means that initially there is no
liability on the cds
however if it becomes clear that w only
receives a payment of two
on its incoming debt then it can and
eventually has to
make an update and set its official
recovery to one half
to notify the other nodes that it can
only make one half of its payments
and it is only at this point that the
liability on the corresponding cds is
modified to one
then if later on update ensures that w
gets three units of payments then w can
again make an update to a new record
rate of three quarters
which changes the liability on the cds
to one health
so looking at the previous example from
this sequential perspective
initially both u and v have an official
recovery rate of one
so there is no liability on their
incoming contracts
this means that both of them have zero
assets and one liability so both of them
can make an update
at this initial stake assume that u is
the first to make an update
announcing a new recovery rate of zero
this will mean that the source node now
has a payment of location of two towards
v
so v now avoids a default and does not
have to make an update anymore
and the sequential process just stops at
this point
on the other hand if the process begins
by v announcing the default
then u gets a payment of 2 from the
source node and it does not have
to update anymore so altogether the
final outcome of the process
depends on whether u or v is the first
node to make an update
also these are the only two possible
ways that the sequential process can go
so this third equilibrium we have seen
is not reachable at all in the
sequential model
we can never end up in this as a final
state
to see some other interesting properties
of this sequential approach
here's another example in this network
the official recovery rate of v is
initially won
so there is no payment obligation on the
cds
this means that u receives no payment so
it has to announce the default
and then v realizes that it also
receives no payment so it also
has to announce the default but then
this now creates a liability of 1 on the
cds
so this gives a new payment of 1 to you
which means that you
comes back from the default and it can
make a new update
setting its recovery rate back to one
and then
similarly we also update the one
however this leads us back to the
initial set of the system where there is
no payment
on the cds so the bank is going to
default again
and we keep periodically repeating the
same steps
note that the system does have an
equilibrium where the recovery rates are
both one half
but we never reach this equilibrium
instead we keep repeating the same few
steps infinitely and the process never
terminates
so these two examples already show some
of the most important properties of this
sequential model
we've seen that nodes can occasionally
come back from a default if they acquire
new assets
later in the network we've also seen
that not every equilibrium of the
network can be reached as a final
outcome
we've seen that the sequential process
might keep on going indefinitely and
not stabilize after any number of
updates and finally
we've seen that the outcome of the
process is heavily dependent on the
order
in which we execute the updates of
specific nodes
and we are going to look into these last
two questions in a bit more detail
to see if we can make more observations
on the stabilization time of these
networks
and also whether there is a best
ordering in some sense for these updates
and whether we can find this and in
particular
the two questions are also connected
because stabilization time
is also something that depends on the
order of updates
if you look at this example system which
is essentially a combination of our
previous two examples
then initially each node has an
announced recovery rate of 1
and if u is the first node to report the
default because
it has no assets then this already gives
a valid payment configuration
and so the system already stabilizes
after this first step
on the other hand if v is the first node
to report the default
then there will be no payment going to
this upper part of the system
and one can observe that in this case
this upper part is equivalent to a
previous example system that never
stabilizes
so based on our choice of the first note
to make an update the system can either
stabilize after one step
or not stabilize at all
so given that even a small part of the
system can produce such an infinite
behavior it's hard to say many
meaningful things about stabilization
time in general
however we make one more observation
namely that the process can also last
very long when we do have stabilization
more specifically we can develop a
construction where the process takes an
exponential number of steps but after
this
it does stabilize eventually and
moreover this holds for any possible
ordering in the system
this construction is much more involved
than the previous examples
but the main idea behind it is that we
can come up with the gadget that
represents a mutable binary variable
and also gadgets that can capture states
and transitions between these states
allowing us to simulate the state
machine or finite automaton
and then using these tools we can build
a binary counter
on tetan bits which counts from zero
to the maximum value on these bits and
after this counting has stopped
the network stabilizes
furthermore note that besides providing
an example for a long but finite
stabilization time
this network is also interesting because
it also suggests that these financial
networks could be
essentially used as a model of
computation and studied from this more
theoretical perspective
in terms of comparing different
orderings it's also a natural question
to ask if we can find the best ordering
that
produces the most favorable outcome in
some sense
from a financial authority's perspective
one natural goal would be
to find the ordering that produces the
smallest number of defaulting banks
in the final outcome of course one can
again create an example
showing that this is highly dependent on
the ordering
in the system if v is the first to
announce the default
then the process terminates with a
single default while if u is the first
to announce
a default then all these nodes in the
lower chain will
eventually end up in a default and one
can also show that in general finding
this best ordering is an empty hard
problem
through a reduction from the max set
problem intuitively we can use our first
example system to represent
a binary variable which evaluates to
true or false depending on whether the
upper or lower node reports a default
first
and then we can also easily devise a
closed gadget where a bank avoids a
default
exactly if one of the literals in the
corresponding clause is set to true
so the whole reduction idea here is
rather straightforward
another possible approach is to look at
it from the perspective of a single bank
and to see if this bank can achieve a
better outcome for itself
by making an update at a specific time
in our first example we have already
seen that this can indeed be the case
with late defaulting
in this system you and we were both
motivated to delay their default
announcement for
as long as possible because if the other
node reports a default earlier then
this means that they can avoid the
default entirely so as you might expect
delaying your default announcement can
be a good strategy in some cases
what's much more surprising is that it
turns out that early defaulting
can also be a good idea in some cases
one can construct a system where the
only way that a node can avoid the
default in the final state of the system
is that if this node is the first one to
announce the default
and just to scratch the main idea here
you can have a system
where nodes b1 and v2 can report the
default initially
and if v1 is the first to do so then
this
ensures that the defaults in another
part of the system happen in a specific
way
and these defaults then provide newer
sets and liabilities to the first part
of the system
that bring v1 back from the default and
push v2 into default instead
and since the system is symmetrical if
v2 were the first to report the default
then this would lead to the opposite
outcome where v2 survives
and v1 is in default so as surprising as
it sounds
in some cases early defaulting is the
only strategy that allows a note to
survive
in the end of the sequential process
and in general we can also show that
finding the best time to report to
default
is an mph problem even if the rest of
the system is completely predictable
to prove this we can essentially combine
the binary counter construction
with a max out reduction idea on a high
level the bits of the binary counter can
represent the values
of the different variables so the
counting process
essentially enumerates all different
variable assignments
and then we also have a special node v
which can report to default anytime
which immediately terminates the
counting process and then the system
provides newer sets back to v
based on the number of satisfactors in
the formula
so essentially stopping the counter at
the right time corresponds to selecting
the best variable assignment for the
formula
besides studying all these properties of
the model it's also worth asking whether
the sequential model is realistic and if
you look at the basic properties
most of these do not sound that bad for
practice it's only this
infinite running time that seems very
unreasonable
so it is natural to wonder if we can
come up with a different sequential
model variant that does not have this
property
and actually the answer is yes we can by
changing a couple of our assumptions
we can obtain another sequential model
without this property
but i'm only going to sketch the base
idea of this now
one ingredient to this different
sequential model is so-called smart
updates
on a very high level we can sort the
steps of our sequential process
into two categories there are steps that
change the liabilities in the network
through a cds and there are other steps
where a bank
simply adjusts its recovery rate to the
given situation
but this does not change the network of
obligations
and while the second kind of step seems
harmless
it can actually also last for infinitely
long it can happen that even though the
liabilities never change
the updates are only converging to an
equilibrium slowly
so the point of smart updates is to
basically remove this second step
by essentially computing the equilibrium
of the system after each liability
change
which is doable in polynomial time since
for fixed liabilities we
basically have adapt on the network and
then ensure that nodes directly update
to this computed recovery rate
so intuitively this removes the part of
the process that
is about information spreading and this
iterative solving of a fixed point
problem
and keeps the steps that really affect
the obligations in the network
moreover we can also do these smart
updates slightly differently
in a method that we call optimistic
updates where the base idea is the same
we just do the computations a little
differently
essentially the difference here is that
while smart updates will
compute the outgoing payments from any
node by analyzing the network
to see how many assets it has optimistic
updates will handle defaulting
and non-defaulting nodes slightly
differently for defaulting nodes we
again compute the amount of outgoing
payments by analyzing the network
but to the nodes that haven't reported
the default yet we
give the benefit of a doubt and assume
that they can fulfill all their
obligations
even if the current network state
suggests otherwise
so of course this description is far
from formal but we really only want to
give you the general idea of what's
behind these methods
and another modification to our original
model
is liability freezing in our original
setting we have assumed that if
v is in default but the payment
obligation on an incoming cds increases
then this can bring v back from the
default
now in contrast to this liability
freezing assumes that when v
defaults then the liability on its
incoming and outgoing cds
is fixed at the current level forever
essentially turning it into a simple
debt contract
so that even if the reference entity
makes an update in the future
the liability on the edge is not
changing anymore
in practice such a model corresponds to
a setting where there's a larger time
difference between these updates so
by the time the next update happens we
has already gone through the first steps
of the insolvency process
and was expected to cash in all the
incoming payments from
all of its contracts
and the interesting point behind these
changes is that if we combine optimistic
updates with liability freezing
then we obtain a monotone sequential
model
where the recovery rates of every bank
can only decrease with each update
and hence this infinite periodic
behavior can never occur
so this monotonicity means that every
bank can go into default
at most once during the process and with
this
one can also show that the entire
process can never last for more than
quadratically many steps
so stabilization is indeed guaranteed
on the other hand the drawback of this
monotonicity
is that if recovery rates only decrease
then this is a sequential model where
notes can never return from the default
so we have lost another more or less
realistic property from the model
so this already shows that one of the
most natural open questions in this
setting is
whether we can come up with a sequential
model that is even more realistic than
these previous ones
and in particular with one that allows
reversing defaults
but also guarantees stabilization at the
same time
however there are also other aspects of
the model where we could try to get
closer to practical financial systems
for example by introducing some form of
concurrency or
a setting with incomplete information
and with that i thank you for your
attention and i'm happy to answer any
questions in the live session